wir alle wollen grünen nachhaltigen und
sauberen Strom doch ein Problem dabei
wird gerne verschwiegen Windräder
enthalten Bauteile die wiederum ein
ziemlich exotisches Gas enthalten es
heißt Schwefel hexaflorid SF6 und was
ist das Problem daran ein Kilo davon ist
so klimaschädlich wie 23.000 kg
Kohlendioxid die sorgen schon heute für
mehr Treibhauseffekt als der gesamte
innerdeutsche Flugverkehr über die Zeit
in der Atmosphäre immer weiter
anreichern das gefährlichste
Treibhausgas überhaupt sind Windräder
wirklich Teil des Problems statt der
Lösung das ard-format Plus Minus lässt
es ja so aussehen Spoiler nein sie sind
es nicht wir gehen die Doku einmal durch
und erklären dir was du über SF6
wirklich wissen musst
[Musik]
klären wir zuerst einmal die Basics
Schwefelhexafluorid kurz SF6 ist ein
Treibhausgas und zwar das stärkste das
wir kennen die Treibhauswirkung ist nach
100 Jahren über 25.000 Mal so hoch wie
die von CO2 und ja der ARD Beitrag hat
gerade 23.000 gesagt aber wir haben noch
mal nachgeguckt und wir sind tatsächlich
25.184 mal so viel das bedeutet dass ein
Kilogramm imitiertes SF6 so
klimaschädlich ist wie eine PKW Strecke
von rund 125
000 km oder 8 Flüge auf die Malediven
und zurück ein einzelnes Kilogramm SF6
ist ziemlich reaktionsträger das
bedeutet dass es zum Beispiel 3200 Jahre
lang in unserer Atmosphäre verweilt und
weil es reaktionsträger ist wird SF6
gerne als Isolator in Schaltanlagen
eingesetzt z.B auch in der Windkraft um
Lichtbögen und Kurzschlüsse zu
verhindern okay aber wie groß ist unser
Problem mit SF 16 jetzt genau mehr
Treibhauseffekt als der gesamte die
deutsche Flugverkehr Tendenz steigend
nun solange das System geschlossen ist
hat das Gas natürlich gar keine
treibhauswirkungen es bleibt einfach
dort wo es Kurzschlüsse verhindern soll
aber bei einem Defekt oder Leck kann SF6
natürlich austreten und deshalb fordern
Forscher schon seit den 90er Jahren dass
die Suche nach alternativen gefördert
wird tritt den regelmäßig SF6 aus wäre
jetzt die nächste Frage nun die
deutschen Gesamtemissionen von SF6 im
Jahr 2018 entsprachen etwa 4,4 Millionen
Tonnen CO2 äquivalente der innerdeutsche
Flugverkehr hat wiederum im selben Jahr
2,4 Millionen Tonnen ausgestoßen die
Aussage stimmt also die Deutschen
sf6-emissionen sind 2018 für ein halbes
Prozent der Treibhausgasemissionen
verantwortlich gewesen der innerdeutsche
Flugverkehr für etwas weniger als 0,3 %.
okay aber wie setzen diese Emissionen
sich eigentlich zusammen das hier sind
die SF6 Emissionen in Deutschland und in
pink dargestellt sind die Emissionen aus
windrä
schallschutzscheiben genau SF6 wurde
jahrzehntelang ganz anders eingesetzt
als heute in Schuhsohlen in Autoreifen
oder eben in schallschutzscheiben
Schallschutz
schallschutzscheiben seit 2007 ist das
zwar verboten aber bei der Entsorgung
entweicht das Gas auch jetzt noch in die
Atmosphäre die Emissionen aus Windrädern
fallen in die Kategorie elektrische
Betriebsmittel aber ganz wichtig
elektrische Betriebsmittel sind alle
möglichen schalt- und verteileranlagen
und die gibt es nicht nur in Windparks
sondern an jedem größeren Gebäude in
jedem Viertel und auch an Kohle oder
Atomkraftwerken halt überall da wo Strom
in größeren Mengen verteilt werden muss
es wird aber davon ausgegangen dass die
Emissionen in Deutschland nicht zunehmen
einerseits wird die Verwendung in immer
mehr Anwendungen reguliert und Verboten
andererseits wird auch an Alternativen
und einer besseren Versiegelung
geforscht darum beruhen auch alle
Angaben darüber wie viel SF6 tatsächlich
in die Luft gelangt auf Zahlen der
Industrie tatsächlichen
frische Luft sind viel größer als
bislang gedacht für den Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren werden wir mehr
Schaltanlagen brauchen mit oder ohne SF6
aber das Gas sollte eigentlich nicht
entweichen es bleibt im geschlossenen
System hat keine Klimawirkung und soll
beim Abbau der Anlagen recycelt werden
zumindest hat sich die Industrie dazu
2005 selbst verpflichtet extern
überprüft wird das allerdings nicht und
auch die Emissionsdaten sind Angaben der
Industrie es liegt also ein
Interessenskonflikt vor die aufwendige
Entsorgung und die Aufbereitung kosten
natürlich Geld darum haben wir mal beim
Umweltbundesamt angerufen und gefragt ob
das mit dem Recycling wirklich
funktioniert und dort wurde uns dann
erklärt dass in Deutschland sogar mehr
sr6 recycelt als außer Betrieb genommen
wird das kann etwa an SF6 Importen oder
andere Reparaturen der Anlagen liegen es
gibt also keine stichhaltigen
Anhaltspunkte für fehlendes Recycling
aber eben auch keine Beweise dass alles
perfekt läuft hier gibt es also noch
Aufklärungsbedarf wenn wir uns jetzt
nicht auf diese Angaben verlassen wollen
dann müssen wir den sf6-gehalt in der
Luft messen und da sehen wir global wird
deutlich mehr SF6 imitiert als angegeben
regionale Modelle zeigen aber dass diese
mehr Emissionen vor allem aus Ostasien
stammen es wird geschätzt dass China
etwa zehnmal so viel imitiert wie
Westeuropa da aber gäbe es eine
Selbstverpflichtung der Hersteller ob
sie sachgemäß handeln oder das Gas
einfach entweichen lassen kontrolliert
nur die Industrie selbst aber gut nehmen
wir mal an dass das Recycling gar nicht
klappt alles SF6 aus einem mittleren
Windrad würde einfach in die Atmosphäre
entweichen was wären die Folgen der
einzige Hersteller der seine Zahlen zu
SF6 offen liegt ist Vesters nach diesen
Zahlen werden etwa 7,2 kg pro Windrad in
der Turbine und den Schaltanlagen
eingesetzt einerseits Emissionen mit
einer Klimawirkung von etwa 180 Tonnen
CO2 aber Wind Energie spart eben auch
CO2 ein die Zahlen schwanken hier je
nach Bauart und Ort zwischen wenigen
tausend und über 10 Millionen CO2 pro
Jahr und ein Windrad ist im Schnitt 20
bis 25 Jahre am Netz ein Windrad das
komplett sein SF6 verlieren würde würde
also selbst im schlimmsten Fall
innerhalb von zwei Wochen alles wieder
ausgleichen so ein Szenario zeigt uns
wie wichtig die Kontrolle und
Transparenz bei großen Systemen ist wie
es bei der Windenergie um die Emissionen
steht das wissen wir ja jetzt aber wie
steht es eigentlich mit euren Daten im
Internet denn die Menge an persönlichen
Informationen die online über uns
verfügbar ist hat extrem zugenommen und
wächst immer weiter das Problem ist man
weiß gar nicht welche Daten über einen
überhaupt gesammelt und wo sie
gespeichert werden und noch viel
wichtiger werden sie verkauft wir haben
heute einen neuen Sponsor hier auf dem
Kanal inkognit und der agiert quasi als
euer
Datenschutzbeauftragter überall im
Internet hinterlasst ihr Daten die von
sogenannten data Bro kann gesammelt und
weiterverkauft werden es kann alles sein
von eurem Namen über eure Adresse bis
hin zu euren Bankdaten mit inkognit
könnt ihr genau sehen wer diese Daten
über gesammelt hat und den kognit stellt
dann automatisch für euch
datenlöschungsanträge an die jeweiligen
Broker dafür müsst ihr nur eure e-mail
eingeben und inkogni beginnt sofort mit
der Arbeit bei mir wurden zum Beispiel
direkt 60 Anträge gestellt und ich
konnte sofort sehen welche Art von Daten
die Broker über mich haben und für
welche Zwecke sie sie verkaufen wollen
wenn ihr auch wollt dass eure Daten aus
dem Netz verschwinden und sie niemand
mehr weiter verkaufen kann dann schaut
mal bei inkognit vorbei unter
inkognitive.com / Watson und gebt den
Code dr Watson ein dann bekommt ihr
nämlich 60% Rabatt auf ein Jahresabo so
schützt sie nicht nur euch und eure
Daten sondern unterstützt auch uns und
unsere Videos danke dafür Link ist unten
in der Videobeschreibung und falls ihr
euch doch nicht ganz sicher seid dann
habt ihr natürlich 30 Tage Geld zurück
Garantie
okay zurück zu SF6 oder besser nicht
denn das non plus ultra wäre natürlich
Windräder schallschutzscheiben
Autoreifen und Schaltanlagen ohne SF6
wie sieht es also mit den Alternativen
aus zum Standard werden Anlagen ohne
Klimakiller erst wenn der in der EU
verboten ist in Autoreifen und
schallschutzscheiben wurde SF6 ja
bereits 2007 verboten seitdem wird es
dort vor allem durch Luft ersetzt wenn
noch alles so einfach wäre um die SF6
Kurzschlüsse in Schaltanlagen zu
verhindern kann man auch Luft und Vakuum
einsetzen aber man denkt auch über
Feststoffe und andere Gase nach deswegen
rechnen die Experten mit denen wir
gesprochen haben damit das SF6 in
bestimmten Schaltanlagen bald verboten
wird
okay was bedeutet das jetzt alles ja SF6
ist klimaschädlich wir sollten uns
unbedingt um Alternativen bemühen und
dafür sorgen dass die Industrie sich
nicht mehr nur selbst kontrolliert und
wo es vermeidbar ist sollte Nummer 6
verboten werden aber SF6 ist kein
Problem der Windenergie der ard-beitrag
von plusminus stellt es trotzdem so da
und sie lassen in ihrem Beitrag gekonnt
aus dass SF6 auch an vielen anderen
Stellen im Energie und Elektroniksektor
eingesetzt wird und wurde damit haben
sie auch der AFD Zündstoff gegeben die
versucht jetzt mit diesem Argument den
Ausbau der Windkraft zu verlangsamen
unter Videos und Texten zum Thema SF6
tummeln sich jetzt windkraftgegnern die
sich Uhr plötzlich fürs Klima
interessieren wir kennen das ja von
anderen Diskussionen E-Autos werden
populär und auf einmal interessieren
sich Kritiker für den Lithium Abbau den
es auch vorher schon gehabt sobald
jemand vegan ist interessieren sich
andere plötzlich für den Regenwald der
angeblich für Tofu gerodet wird und ein
Windrad wird geplant und plötzlich
werden die Gegner zu Vogelschützern ein
Beitrag der einordnet und abwägt ist
nicht zu attraktiv und aufwühlend wie
einer der nach Blockbuster und
Weltuntergang klingt wir brauchen einen
konstruktiven Austausch denn solche
Themen wie SF6 müssen diskutiert werden
aber eben Fakten basiert und vollständig
statt mit Megafon und Desinformationen
in diesem Sinne bleibt neugierig euer
Cedric